غاريفي ، أنت خبير يعرف كل شيء ،
يمكنك تقديم المشورة لنا بشأن الأعمال التجارية ، يمكنك تقديم المشورة لنا
بشأن الحياة ، فأنت
متحدث تحفيزي لرائد الأعمال مثل بجدية ،
والقائمة تطول ، وأنا سعيد جدًا لأنك معنا
هنا اليوم ، وأشكرك أيضًا
الكثير من التسويف ، حسنًا ،
إنها لعنة حياتنا في وقت ما ، هل
يمكنك أن تخبرنا كيف يمكننا التعامل مع هذه العادة ،
نعم أعتقد أنه عندما أفكر في
التسويف ، فإن ما يحدث حقًا
هو أن الناس يخبرون أنهم في
الواقع خائفون من الفشل أمام
الآخرين  يماطل معظم الناس بسبب
أحد أمرين ، الخوف والخوف
هو الشيء الوحيد الذي أرغب في
محاربته في العالم ، فهم في الواقع
قلقون حقًا من أنهم إذا فعلوا هذا
الشيء ولم يسير على ما يرام
والدتهم خالتهم  أفضل صديق
لأختهم ،
سيحكم عليهم زميلهم في العمل وهم
يعيشون حياتهم بشكل أساسي بناءً على
رأي شخص آخر أو رقم اثنين
وهذا الشخص مثير جدًا للاهتمام ، لكنهم
حقًا لا يحبونه ،
شكرًا لك